eufracia urtado is worried about getting
this
oxygen tank filled for her mother and
sister who are ill at home with covet
19.
days before polls open eufracia says her
family is facing the raging pandemic
alone
and the elections are not all that
important
the candidates aren't doing anything for
us they don't stick to their promises
it's only words
unfortunately it's a great
disappointment i'll vote blank because
they are all the same
recent opinion polls say nearly 30
percent of peruvians may vote blank or
null
because they can't find anyone who
represents them many peruvians are
worried about some candidates on the
ballot
of the 18 presidential candidates the
front runner is a former congressman who
was once suspended
for sexual harassment another
a respected economist relies on advice
from a comedian
and there's a religious
ultra-conservative businessman
who owes the treasury millions and
openly insults
anyone he dislikes on the campaign trail
none of the presidential candidates have
more than a 13
approval rating analysts say the
elections couldn't be held at a worse
time
it's as if the titanic was going down
and someone said
let's choose a new captain but
everyone's looking for a lifeboat
the political scene is so weak and
limited that there's no large
group of voters who perceives any of the
candidates as a good option
the last presidential term was rocked by
political instability with three
precedents unseated during that period
a congress dissolved a congressional
coup and violent protests
an interim leader was finally sworn in
last november
after five years of political upheaval
the impact of the pandemic has pushed
peru deeper
into political and economic chaos and
many believe
the elections will not guarantee
political stability
with 18 candidates and 20 political
parties competing the next congress will
likely be fragmented
for jocelyn palomino the elections will
be useless
nothing is solved there are no vaccines
i'm frustrated not knowing when this
crisis will stop
there are no jobs it's sad so many
people we love are dying
and we have no support it's very sad
with a vote so divided there will be a
balance
and that could mean that the next
president could be a lame duck
from day one mariana peru